whoa that's a high rating playing zip
zip elephant and who is that actually is
there a name our team EF Huawei's got a
super high rating that some one of the
most talented Russian players his um 16
or 17 and 26 something grand master 2
670 or something and while heights I
rating okay I'll go for the Kings Indian
and see what he does against that often
at least making for interesting play
yeah that is the chrome neck Nakamura
line that I have never really looked at
didn't Cromley go back to the two I
think he did okay place more than the
typical style of the Petrosian system
well before was a threat maybe maybe we
can go Ruby one end directly before here
yeah I cannot go a for you can just take
that and so maybe him so that I have
okay I've night a for if I need to yeah
this is probably necessary to get it
have five in the first place interesting
it's an interesting choice if i take now
can either take now it could be
interesting it takes with the pawn I
mean he cannot castle maybe this is
worth something look at for as an
interesting try I can always call Bishop
f2 though I am so we will always be able
to castle because of this maybe this 193
is a threat and and so it takes it hmm
it's in a bad position for me I don't
know it looks fatty okay he hasn't
canceled yet and well Bishop f2 I don't
know maybe he threatens to taking take
my c-5m my c5 night
yeah so it's an interesting situation
even taking that that Bishop is not
completely completely out of the out of
the picture but I think this is not bad
is it
I mean it cannot be bad just when i
wasn't sure if i have something
something nice now we will probably
castle playing normal moves let's say
and i'm not sure that this was all know
and it's got a ch3 cannot go to the
seven okay night night okay i'll go oops
i go back it's probably not so great
with the night on a six
zip elephant that's probably the
Siberian elephant one thing I know that
it's not real world species that there
is no Siberian elephant but i think the
night in Russians I have half the night
is actually the elephant okay I'm i
think i have rook takes f2 sometimes
here King takes Queen check Kim Ji Won
Bishop e3 check case hmm is preventing
that almost I have Quincy five also
until you do against that just attacking
the night cannot go to f3
night doesn't have good squares it's a
pretty uncomfortable move to phase where
i can take here now not sure how good
that is right before takes Queen takes
at the end that's not be five um yeah I
have to do that I mean okay that was the
plan reply
it takes it I can take with the night
for possible 94 yeah I'll be
materialistic they're all yeah let's do
that just keep that pawn
one minute 20 k it's not not hopelessly
behind on time t8 is going to should be
six I can check here though maybe let's
do that time when I just grab things
Trixie 54 Bishop e3 if he takes be 70
will reply must make sure not to fall
too far behind him timewise
yeah that was what I expected we know
maybe just move it here for okay too I'm
going to get it back 96 rupee six check
check all right five twenty-something
seconds check check I shoot that didn't
see that one coming I don't have a good
square them check check
now you win on time it was a good fight
though I think I pretty much outplayed
him and even that is okay check check
check jack for it I got a draw but it
took me too long that complications to
which along where else was a good game i
pretty much all played this guy round
here it got got very tricky yeah I don't
think that this is any good Queen g5 I'm
just clearly better yeah I will probably
find a couple of minutes now if I
analyze this with with them with the
engine okay that was right and do I have
a win here yeah queen h phi f is good
for Bishop f4 wow yeah that's true age
three Bishop e2 yeah that's the kind of
stuff i mean you can play in tournament
chess so it's not so easy for me to find
in blitz this is also enough for a big
advantage I just not so easy I was
always a little bit down on the clock up
to here i'm i'm okay i think it was a
nice little trick here that i had this
for Bishop e3 but why he always kept
kept the game going and here probably in
fact the draw is the most likely result
check but I spend a little bit too much
check too much time and check it's a
draw up to dry up to the final the ping
up to the final position
check check check and check you can I
mean you cannot get a block there of
that diagonal and push the people or
something like that it's just just a
draw yeah what was a very good fight
against that very strong talented
Russian junior player I hope you enjoyed
the game thanks for watching